des traces de pas de dinosaures ont été
découvertes dans le lit d'une rivière
texane à cause de la sécheresse voici ce
qu ont lancé ces traces inédites ont été
découvertes dans la rivière pas l'udc 6
au coeur de la dinosaures valait une
région du texas proche de dallas déjà
reconnu pour ses nombreuses traces de
dinosaures selon les premières analyses
ces traces dateraient d'il ya 113
millions d'années et auraient été
laissées par un accroc quant aux russes
un prédateur bipèdes qui pouvait mesurer
cinq mètres et peser 7 tonnes les traces
de la crau quant aux russes étaient
préalablement enfouis rempli de
sédiments et recouverte d'eau ce qui a
aidé à leur conservation selon le parc
dinosaures valais il pourrait s'agir de
l'une des plus longues suites de traces
de pas de dinosaures au monde cependant
avec le retour de la pluie les trois ont
bientôt revenir sous l'eau et ne seront
plus visibles
[Musique]